alex rodriguez is moving on from his
ex-fiance
jennifer lopez she's really funny and
amazing
and she's just magical a source tells
e.t that while the former mlb star
initially held out hope that he and the
51 year old triple threat could
reconcile
he's now accepting that it's just not in
the cards
we really have a special connection that
way so
yeah he was he was amazing back in april
the two announced in a joint statement
that they were calling off their
engagement
jen since moved on with ben affleck the
pair was previously engaged from 2002
to 2004. when jennifer and alex first
split he wanted to work things out and
still held on to hope that he and jayla
would get back together
but he's come to terms with the fact
that it's over now
the source says that alex is very aware
of the attention surrounding jen
and ben but he's trying to focus on
himself and his future instead
one month before jlo and a-rod announced
their split
multiple sources told et that the two
had called off their engagement
with one source noting that the former
couple decided their relationship had
run
its course but one day later a source
told et that the two were continuing
their relationship
and working through things adding that
no third party was involved
at the time jen mocked the breakup
headlines with this tick tock
i ain't worried about a blog you're done
speaking on my moves like this news you
alex tagged jen in this instapost
writing new week
new day onward upward fast forward to
april
and the couple announced their split for
good releasing a statement that read in
part
quote we have realized we are better as
friends and look forward to remaining so
the former new york yankee star also
shared this emotional video on his
instagram story
you can hear coldplay's fix you playing
as he films
several framed photos with jennifer and
their kids
my girls uh adore jennifer she's uh
she's a great role model i'm the
luckiest father in the world to to be
able to
you expose my beautiful daughters to
someone as brilliant
as jennifer as for jen and ben a source
told et in may that alex was surprised
by how quickly she moved on after their
breakup
adding quote alex understands that
jennifer is single but felt shocked by
her and ben's quick meetup
at the end of the day alex wants
jennifer to be happy but the way
everything has unfolded doesn't sit well
with him
i'm thrilled you know me i was super
happy now a source tells et that jen and
ben have picked up where they left off
after all these years
and even though they planned to take
things slow their strong connection has
made it hard to do so
quote jennifer and ben are very into one
another
and in a short time are very serious
[Music]